marijuana has been touted as an
effective pain reliever for a variety of
ailments more research is underway but
the legality of cannabis on a federal
level often makes large studies more
difficult but for those who use it for
pain they say the proof is there heather
mills reports on one new study showing
significant help for women
specifically for those suffering
endometriosis pelvic pain certainly
isn't something a lot of women want to
talk about but it is something courtney
patterson felt compelled to do hoping
she can help others dealing with the
same condition
it's a pain that you can't describe
courtney patterson is living with
endometriosis a painful condition that
affects one out of 10 women where the
tissue that lines the inside of the
uterus develops outside which causes a
lot of pain because it's it's excessive
tissue putting pressure on our nerves
hard to diagnose even more difficult to
treat long periods cramping
feeling sick having painful sex so i
didn't know i just knew something wasn't
right the diagnosis is difficult
because it's very obscure pain dr paige
beatty is a former er doc and co-founder
of the sanctuary dispensary the nerve
portion of the pain
is well managed with cannabis in a study
recently published in the public library
of science journal cannabis was found to
be highly effective for women suffering
the pain of endometriosis one of the
solutions could be and should be
cannabis for patterson it helped
immensely i need stuff that's
immediately and that's an immediate
result patterson has had multiple
surgeries to remove the excess tissue in
her uterus there's no cure for
endometriosis she's only delaying an
eventual hysterectomy by keeping the
pain at bay now i'm not saying that it
makes it go away it's just i'm able to
live everyday life with not being so
much in pain dr beatty who also owns a
pain management clinic was part of
former nevada governor brian sandoval's
opiate task force he says he understands
the need to suppress pain and also the
need to do so safely we are doing a
study a double-blind study to replace
opiates with cannabis and to benefit
from cannabis dr beatty says it doesn't
have to have thc that's the component
that makes you feel high and you don't
have to smoke it we have tinctures
there's edibles there's a whole the
whole slew of ways of taking cannabis
for patterson she says she knows what
works to get through her pain so she can
continue living her life to the fullest
i need results and i need it now and
that's the fastest thing dr beatty says
as the stigma of marijuana use continues
to wane he is seeing a lot more people
and women come in for the health
benefits of cannabis heather mills live
local now